les agriculteurs réparé la nature
régulièrement accusées d'arracher un
arbre est indispensable à la
biodiversité certains agriculteurs
al'inverse reboiser parfois massivement
c'est le cas de ce céréalier bio de sa
zee dans le chinonais avec une trentaine
de bénévoles il a planté ce week-end sur
ces parcelles un millier d'arbres une
façon d'offrir un habitat d'ici quelques
années aux plantes et aux animaux
nous sommes dans le chinonais sur une
parcelle agricole de céréales bio depuis
les années 70 sur ses terres plus de
haies bocagères ni d'arbres pour faire
de l'ombre aux cultures la conséquence
du remembrement
pourtant ce samedi là ils sont une
trentaine de bénévoles à vouloir changer
la donne tous les cinq mètres il plante
un arbre afin de favoriser le retour de
la biodiversité mille arbres ont ainsi
été prévu sur 13 hectares une action
nature à laquelle participent les slits
et sa fille alice toutes les deux vivent
ta tour nord et n'ont pas forcément la
main verte je suis venu partager un bon
moment avec ma fille en pleine nature
j'habite en appartement sur un tout
petit balcon donc j'avais vraiment envie
de me mettre au travail de faire quelque
chose de concret
planter des arbres de voir ce travail
dont le futur est d'aider les gens bon
j'en ai planté way dans la dizaine
déranger des rangées d'arbres en plus ça
ferait pas de mal à la planète parce que
je pense aux êtres qui vont vivre après
nous qui sont en train de naître et qui
si on fait pas de bons gestes qui vont
pas peut-être qu'ils vont pas avoir faim
la chance que nous on aille donc je
pense que c'est important d'aider la
nature à se reproduire ces futurs
corridor végétaux vont pousser sur les
terres d'un jeune agriculteur céréalier
installé depuis trois ans a failli leur
mission ralentir notamment l'érosion des
sols et le dessèchement des terres en
voyant ce paysage qui était un peu
devenu un peu monotone quoi
ça m'a posé question je me suis demandée
ben
vas-y un rêve qui est un rêve que que la
nature reprenne ses droits en fait le
paysan c'est celui qui est le gardien de
la nature en fête c'est vraiment son
rôle premier si lui ne fait pas qui va
le faire à sa place en 2021 40 demandes
des deux d'agriculteurs qui souhaitaient
reboiser leurs parcelles ont été
formulées auprès de la ce et pentes
l'association d'étude de protection et
d'aménagement de la nature en touraine
qui est également partenaire de cette
opération
neuf ont pu être aider dans cette
démarche dix autres le seront en 2022